[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hallo zusammen heute machen wir haltet
euch fest eine Apfel Zimt Lasagne lasst
euch dieses Wort mal auf der Zunge
zergehen also jetzt ist wieder so
Apfelzeit eigentlich das ganze Jahr über
aber gerade im Herbst habe ich jetzt die
besten und genialsten Rezepte für euch
ausgepackt und wir starten jetzt erstmal
mit dem Hefeteig der geht auch ganz
schnell total unkompliziert und alle
ganz genauen Mengenangaben schreibe ich
euch wie man unten in die Infobox für
das Video nämlich nie zu lange hat mich
gestalten sondern einfach direkt auf den
Punkt kommen und ich gebe jetzt
zuallererst in meine Küchenmaschine Mehl
allerdings behalte ich ein bisschen was
zurück einfach damit ich es später
Nacharbeiten kann ein bisschen mehr es
kommt zurück und das gebe ich nach und
nach dazu wir wollen nämlich einen
geschmeidigen Hefeteig und je nachdem
was für ein Ei ihr gleich verwendet
Größe M oder L braucht halt ein bisschen
mehr oder ein bisschen weniger Mehl und
ich nehme jetzt Trockenhefe weil ich
habe keine frische darf Trockenhefe habe
ich immer da Äpfel habe ich auch immer
da eigentlich habe ich alle Zutaten
immer dafür dieses Rezept und ich
verrühre jetzt eigentlich alle Zutaten
miteinander dass er mit der Maschine
später mit den Händen und dann wird
daraus ein richtig geschmeidiger
Hefeteig
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt nur noch Zucker Milch
Butter und Ei dazu gegeben und der Teig
ist schon echt schön geschmeidig ich
nehme den jetzt aber noch mal auf die
Arbeitsfläche und knete den mit den
Händen kurz zurecht ihr könnt da an der
Stelle ruhig noch ein bisschen Mehl
nehmen also ich habe auch nicht alles
verbraucht das kommt halt wie gesagt
immer auf das Ei an nur vorher alles
rein gibt der Tag euch einmal zu trocken
wird dann könnt ihr das eigentlich gar
nicht mehr rückgängig machen daher immer
ganz wenig einarbeiten und wenn ihr
etwas Überschuss habt auch nicht
verwenden übrigens ist der Teig dann
fertig wenn er sich genauso wie euer
Ohrläppchen anfühlt also gerne mal
fühlen und das ist eins zu eins das
gleiche Feeling das ist voll verrückt
wenn man das gleichzeitig macht das ist
richtig verrückt macht das Maß irgendwie
so das Gefühl
[Musik]
so wenn ihr dann soweit seid einfach
eine Kugel formen und ihr nehmt am
besten Öl also ich nehme jetzt
backtrennspray ich muss jetzt ich darf
jetzt nicht schütteln weil bei allen
backtrennsprays die sind auch alle mit
Alkohol das ist ohne Alkohol das ist die
Besonderheit schüttelt man immer und
dann sprüht man hier nicht schütteln das
muss man sich echt verinnerlichen und
dann einfach reinsprühen und ich will
jetzt extra bewusst nicht mehr Mehl
nehmen damit es eben nicht zu trocken
wird daher auf jeden Falls nicht mit
Mehl benetzen ja
nein ist auch kein Ethanol drin gute
Frage Sarah also ist auch kein Ethanol
drin keinerlei Alkohol deswegen haben
wir da irgendwie 11 12 Monate für
gebraucht jetzt ist es endlich da oben
drüber auch noch mal ein bisschen und
dann zudecken und 45 Minuten lang an
einem warmen Ort gehen lassen
so der Hefeteig ist schon gut
aufgegangen vorab kümmere ich mich jetzt
um die Äpfel und dann nehme ich bei so
süßen Rezepten am liebsten die säuerlich
weil die machen einfach den Geschmack
rund wenn ihr jetzt denkt okay süße
Äpfel passen jetzt zum Süßen Gericht
dann ist es nicht ganz so fein im
Geschmack daher gerne Granny Smith zum
Beispiel nehmen die nehme ich heute
eLSTER ist auch gut also einfach auf die
säuerlichen Sorten achten und das werde
ich jetzt einfach in schöne feine Würfel
schneiden und dann zusammen mit Zimt mit
Zimtzucker vermengen und gerne auch
vorab ein bisschen Zitronensaft drüber
träufeln damit sie nicht ganz so schnell
braun werden
[Musik]
zur Apfelmasse habe ich ganz zum Schluss
noch Speisestärke gegeben und ihr werdet
merken dass der Saft austritt den
brauchen wir gleich tatsächlich nicht
der kann aber jetzt in der Zwischenzeit
schön austreten während wir uns um den
Hefeteig kümmern ich habe jetzt hier
meinen ausrollstab und ich nehme hier
den 3 mm Einsatz falls ihr den jetzt
nicht haben solltet dann könnt ihr euch
ja so eine Art Lineal zur Hilfe nehmen
oder einfach notfalls nach Augenmaß
damit es nicht zu dick ausgerollt wird
und dann brauchen wir drei Mal wir
brauchen nämlich drei Lagen dreimal die
Größe eurer Auflaufform ihr müsst euch
nicht eins zu eins an meine Maße halten
aber so eine ungefähre Richtlinie sind
jetzt 17 x 23 cm und da mache ich es
einfach so bei mir ist es jetzt die
Größe meiner Silikonmatte dass ich drei
Mal quasi die Länge von diesen von
dieser Auflaufform habe und dann kann
ich mir das nämlich den einfach nur
durchschneiden und habe keine große
Arbeit und falls ihr jetzt eine
silikonbackmatte zu Hause habt braucht
ihr keinen extra Mehl da bin ich mal Fan
von damit der auch nicht so trocken wird
sollte eure Arbeitsfläche ein bisschen
anpacken und ankleben dann könnt ihr
ganz wenig Mehl verwenden
[Musik]
ihr werdet auf jeden Fall genug Teig
haben um ganz unten noch so einen
kleinen Rand hoch zu ziehen und dadurch
dass der Teig halt so elastisch und auch
geschmeidig ist könnt ihr das hier ganz
einfach hochziehen und jetzt geben wir
die Apfelfüllung drauf da wie gesagt
darauf achten dass ihr die Flüssigkeit
einfach in der Schüssel lasst und ein
Drittel halt von der
Hälfte die Hälfte von der Gesamtmasse
weil wir füllen jetzt zweimal und eine
mittlere Schicht Teig kommt gleich noch
rein die dritte Teigmasse die kommt
gleich on top und wenn jetzt richtig
crazy Seiten auch gut und Geschmack habt
dann kommt da jetzt noch Karamellsoße
drauf und ich nehme dann einfach meine
trilette-sauce kommt dann einfach
draufgedrittelt und dann Schichte ich
einfach bis ich oben angekommen bin
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt noch auf die Oberfläche
etwas Zimt Zucker gestreut und jetzt
können wir das noch einschneiden einfach
weil die Äpfel oder die Apfelmasse ja
sehr sehr heiß wird und die sucht sich
schon den Weg nach außen also schneiden
wir das vorsorglich einfach ein bisschen
an auch nicht zu viel den Ofen habe ich
schon vorgeheizt auf 190 Grad Ober- und
Unterhitze und jetzt wird erstmal
vorgebacken und zwar mit Alufolie oben
drüber hat was mit der Bräunung zu tun
und in den letzten zehn Minuten muss man
die einfach noch mal ab und packt das
Ganze zu Ende
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Test ist hier live aus dem Story gerade
Feierabend gemacht mega Schiss gewesen
heute ich habe sogar mit frittiert und
richtig Spaß gemacht jetzt geht erstmal
von kostet erstmal die Dame und dann
Melissa ich möchte euch mein Job gehen
[Gelächter]
kennst ja nicht anders
okay Kuschelzeit
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
bis zum nächsten
[Musik]
[Applaus]